what product has changed the world the
most is it google facebook uber how
about the internet 10 years ago nobody
in our audience here was sitting there
with a mobile phone next to their bed 10
years ago the internet access was
largely people's offices and
occasionally at home this connectivity
and mobile revolution has changed
everything it's text text text picture
picture picture where am I going what
does the app say and so forth and so on
it only happened in five years we've
talked about Ali Baba we've talked about
Amazon we've talked about do you think
that's hurt humanity I think it's a huge
benefit wait world you're asking eric
eric schmidt but i actually have asked i
have a strong opinion on this I think
empowering individuals is the best way
to deal with the strategic issues that
we face as a as a society as a country
as a globe right empowered people are
smart human nature is good give them the
tools and let them run does your mom
think that yes it's a fair question as
many people think some level of humanity
has been lost I think when you look at
technology what what products when
somebody said they don't make them like
they used to what products are they were
they talking about no but less you have
everything that we have to talk about 10
years ago there was 10 years ago there
was this huge thing about bowling alone
right bowling along remember the whole
thing everyone's maybe I themselves
they're gonna be isolated right now it's
bowling with everyone all the time okay
I don't want to bowl with anyone well
you have an off button